Let's pray together as we seek the holiness of God and Him
producing it in our hearts.
Father, your holiness
is so much bigger and deeper than we ever knew.
I praise you, Lord, that there is more layers and more
depth and more beauty in your holiness, always
more to be discovered.
Lord, we're desperate. We're desperate to go there.
We're desperate to see the beauty of your character and the moral
goodness of your being. But only you can take us to the place
where we can see it clearly for what it is.
So Lord, I pray that you would do it today.
Lord, I pray that you would take me and my prayer partner here
with us today, and that you would
plunge us deeper and deeper into who you
are, Lord. I pray that you would not just keep us around the
edges of your holiness, barely in contact with you,
barely transformed by the glory of your beauty and moral
purity, but that you would take us deep into the heart of
God, down into the core in the hottest part of the fire,
Lord. Take us to the place where we shine and we glow with
the glory of your holiness in ways we never thought we
could. Lord, there's so much darkness in our world, in our
background, in our family, in our nature.
Oh, we need to glow with the glory of your holiness.
Lord, help us there in that place as we go deeper with you.
We know that deeper levels of holiness are needed, deeper levels of holiness are
possible. So Lord, we just launch out
and we launched ourselves deep into your character.
And we pray, O God, that you would reproduce yourself in us.
Teach us, O Lord, to know the difference between the holy
and the common. Teach us to know the difference between the holy and that which
is impure, and make us find there in the depths of
your holiness, new levels of joy and usefulness and
power and victory in you. We pray in Jesus' name.
Let's continue seeking God together.